oh welcome to Sons of the forest we're
finally playing it right on time
yep the game just launched yeah it just
came out isn't it yep it's new right on
time we're timely Hamish yes
yes
I don't know anything about this game
and I barely remember what happened last
game other than we hated someone's kid
how do you not remember we played it so
much oh I mean I remember the setting I
remember us building and the going into
caves I don't remember the story
uh other than there being like
experiments and they're being a kid we
hated we weren't like super
focused on the story okay good then I'm
definitely ready for this so it's
probably not a big deal
um it's survival in the forest
with sons are we the Suns yeah maybe
plus Corp are you guys in the puff Corp
with me no maybe very slowly loading my
my pee brain internet just can't keep up
bro I'm in the puff Corp yeah I'm in the
puff Corp
I do have a hot fudge milkshake with
chocolate chips and if I'm sure it's
very healthy though
what that's great that's good for you
why did you why do you have a milkshake
we took a lunch break I got food are you
loaded in yet and Calvin hey what's up
Kelvin I'm here I'm with you I hear rain
uh okay bro the puffins are missing
no not the spoilers
helicopter the puffins fight demons
I don't need to look at that anymore I
remember about the puffins are you guys
um seeing what I'm saying
on it
uh-oh
behind you guys
Mark did you just get shooted at uh you
know I I was shooted at oh oh god oh
geez
I see a person with a helmet fish eye
that was the softest helicopter crash oh
never mind
go around ah this guy I feel like I'm
getting spoilers
no it's fine Wade don't worry about it
that's fine will you be the judge if
this guy should have gone around going
on I see what you're saying go around
all the puffins are missing guys oh God
oh yeah I know the puffins I remember
that
uh Barbara okay terrible name Virginia
Virginia
and Edward ah
and then we got Kelvin here Calvin seems
a little antsy uh he knows what's coming
he's already lived it twice
I wonder what's in the other folder
yep well this is rude hey wait a minute
175 centimeters oh hey in like human or
human American measurement and human
measurements yeah uh
uh how
Mark did you meet a friend in a shiny
shiny tracksuit I don't know about
friend
um but I met some oh hey whoa
how long is this flight
not as long as you might hope did you
press a button whoa is that you standing
next to me yeah why was I supposed to
close the laptop a character is all
and you're just like hey white demons
yeah I didn't close the laptop this
whole time guys yeah I know I know you
didn't uh you wanna
hey what in the hell
I didn't dude I didn't mean to throw the
rock into your face what the hell also
hey why it wasn't me it was the ocean
fisheye Calvin nobody I knew the ocean
was bad for us the ocean is such a piece
of [__] man trust me
and how did I miss it was right on your
I mean the ocean take that touch the
ocean sucks at throwing bro I think I
wait Kelvin just swim around the
helicopter the Air's not under it uh
he's seeing it he's seeing it he's
seeing it do you see that guy over there
kind of riding around a lot oh man
nah man okay no okay are you sure
nah
he's really Rising aggressively but
making no effort to like stand whoa hey
hey wait what happens if I do this I
love that what am I doing right now I
love Mouse sincity not having any effect
in the game
oh Jesus in here I'm what am I doing to
you what is this you're holding your
hand down to me and moving your fingers
threateningly now you gotta Rock now
you're casting a spell I think
yeah whoa look at that guy whoa whoa
wow
I don't know what you're talking about
this is my license plate
nope I'm on the ground
ah emergency pack
oh how are you
huh
oh there's steaks
whoa oh yeah
oh
look the gear to open the emergency pack
man this guy doesn't look good guys he's
hi why Why Stop casting a spell hey guys
I found an emergency pack
um
it came with a book wow nice book what
you want to do is put sticks under a
tarp and that's your tent right there
all right
so just so everyone's on the same page
can that guy stop groaning for one
second whoa
oh there's a light
light no way it's our my backpack is RGB
guys why are you bloody I may have
accidentally clubbed him oh bloody dude
the backpack is RGB
sweet
I hate it mooglies what's RGB your
backpack the backpack bro bro get on the
backpack wait I got I got a whole bunch
of stuff
got cases backpack is just a Black
Backpack are you sure yeah you sure you
sure bro a walkie-talkie oh [__] hey
guys my bag is RGB
hey I don't know how I function
sometimes hello hello can you hear me
hello can you hear me can you hear me
hello hello
man that was terrible quality
oh man I hear you oh yeah
I'm not
I don't know I'm not getting that I'm
not getting it guys I hear you I hear
you and I hear you through me me through
you me through you hello
yo what's up yo what's up I'm not uh
Jesus Christ
yeah let's agree to never do that again
except as punishment I feel like that's
only appropriate
all right can I talk to this guy Whoa
man what a drama queen here you talk to
him I'll just go around and get these
grenades sounds good boys oh thanks boys
I love that love you boys
guys I got some nine mil ammo and some
Buckshot uh-huh let's go
whoa what the hell man
what did you just do uh he's arriving in
pain
my boy oh geez let me hello uh fisheye
or uh Mad Eye what the hell is his name
Calvin Kelvin he didn't go around that
was his problem
Calvin Kelvin
oh what in the hell is wrong with you
I'm sorry I was just seeing if kelvin's
okay yeah Calvin are you okay that was
not okay
he's good oh he's good Kelvin
hello Calvin uh all right uh follow me I
guess
yeah he's good this backpack spreads out
into the world's largest everything over
here Putin Putin the Puffin family not
the Putin family
oh
a shield
friend
follow me all right we got a friend go
you can have him get stuff yeah I know
oh yeah
fire
clear whoops I didn't mean to do that oh
what's what does clear five meters mean
where are you going bud what are you
doing buddy in five meters probably okay
oh no not me not me oh he's clearing
he's he's clearing away he's not he's
not threatening you man he's holding
your ass [__] and walking at me holding
a hatchet and walking towards him uh
take clear take it take a break buddy
take a break five meters
all right I'm gonna go see if these
other guys are okay don't make fun of
them
[Music]
hello other humans what's the point of
this game what's the point of this game
survive I see
do you guys see me am I Ma I see yeah I
see you guys these guys have
endoskeletons is that the right word no
um
spiders I don't see spiders spiders
spiders spiders what are you talking
spiders nothing's happening Bob there's
no spiders spiders
because
no spiders spot
zero spots
there's zero no spiders no spiders
repeat no spiders spiders
I killed the spider guys don't worry
there's no spider guys I killed the
spider look it's dead spider look I got
it I'm I'm disappeared
there's no spider uh should we uh Kelvin
um hey Kelvin how you doing these guys
look very
um not bloody for how spiky they look
this guy's skull is on the outside oh
that's cool
is that good or I don't know oh neat
he's like a cockroach man
he's shaking his head this guy doesn't
like
oh hell yeah whoa he's getting sticks
yeah he's getting sticks and he's gonna
give him to me all right well this game
basically plays itself what are we gonna
do next guys those are big streaks you
guys want to take a break pick it up
next episode
what thank you all for watching stay
tuned for uh what happened
[Music]
we uh don't you touch Kelvin
yeah that's gonna happen to you
oh no those weren't for you Mark we took
the K the Kelvin sticks he took them I
told Kelvin to give go gather sticks and
give them to me that's what I told him
he didn't he gave him to me oh really
that's gonna be your butt it's gonna be
yours
frenulum it's gone say goodbye to your
frenulum [__] you guys know what I wish
we could tell Kelvin to do hey whoa whoa
what the hell man I wish I want to tell
him to go listen to our hit podcast
distractible oh that's a good idea is
that one of the options yeah yeah go go
up to him uh get out your book and just
be like yeah
Kelvin let me see follow me on
distractible
yeah
hold on scroll down D no oh get
distractible hey what's up man you
scared you scared all right let's be
scared we gotta build him a shelter man
let's have him actually just have him
you know what that's true that's true
I'm gonna have him build a fire I don't
know where he's gonna build it but he's
gonna build one look if any of you heard
Kelvin I'm going to blow up this island
with atomics can we Define hurt
yeah if you heard him can we tell him
can we just have him build stuff
I think
whoa
hey I found a grenade they work
hey wait I have something for that
Bob ivito Wade's existence
oh
Paul oh
I did that and you disappeared
oh damn it we never get back underwater
look what you did Bob wait Mark I veto
Bob's existence ivito Bob's existence
why are you out there go around what is
this
go around
why am I oh oh I see
interesting
uh
where am I where am I oh hey we're
together friend I hate you
what do you mean Bob blew us up Bob did
you blow us up I'd simply remember I
don't recall Wade blowing me up I got it
knocked down Bob got us knocked knock
knocked up he got us knocked Downer Bob
knocked us up
bro bro bro come here come here all
right whatever I got what I got did I
build a fire whoa Calvin built a build a
thingy Calvin look kelvin's the best
mine
Kelvin is already better than either of
you two and I want to point that out
whoa I told him
I'm here so I get credit for that I'm
going to bed oh my God Mark I just got a
seagull out of the air wow you know I'm
so good your violence is not exactly
impressive to me uh
thank you yeah but that's what I'm
saying it's not impressive to me I'm not
impressed by your violence oh hey Bob I
found something else for you to be
violent to
yes
ooh the tree oh my God guys Kelvin lit a
fire inside the tent what better place
to do it
well I mean
how do I summon Kelvin is there like a
whistle or a flare he's kind of deaf
Calvin
those are backpack somebody died
well I picked it back up
I didn't yeah I figured
wow that tree just
imploded that tree was not okay
emotionally and just crumbled the bits
are any of us really okay emotionally
Calvin's giving me a big thumbs up guys
tell you what that's what a guy what a
guy what a guy he's one of you I'll get
one of you eventually
oh my God he's sitting over here just
having the time of his life dude
Calvin's a party you guys seen Kelvin
right now no
he's sitting by the fire just basking in
it right now he's basking you know what
you deserve it bro you're real you're
real Bud Calvin tell you what he's a bud
my blood
I don't know what have you done for me
lately
I went and got my backpack I tried to
lead you to an innocent creature to
murder
you did try and give me an innocent
creature to murder this is true was it
me was me the innocent creature because
I was murdered in this case no he
already murdered you I mean Bob [__]
you up yeah what about you that's that's
you went down like like a bag of dicks
shut up you went down just as hard like
a box of dicks oh hey Bob you're still
here
uh hang on I'm trying to get Kelvin to
help Mark I don't need help you seem
like you need help why yeah I agree with
Bob
uh he's killing both sides Bob Wade's
playing both sides
only on Bob's side but remember we were
an alliance against Bob who blew us up
yeah remember Wade
uh that was a long time ago I forgiven
him a creature to murder yeah
that was you did that was very quick and
very brutal I don't know
also there's weird oh the ground
underneath you is not doing normal oh my
God that Turtle had a chicken wing in it
oh wait I'm eating the
that's fine what okay is that what
turtles are made of
boil what am I doing uh
whatever you're doing stop it I don't
like it oh and Mark come take a look at
this I don't wanna Mark spiders what
there's no spiders more spiders I know
there's not
oh
back off Mark you're gonna come take a
look at this no I don't
oh you do all right fine Jesus what's
wrong
why is Kelvin on the ground
it's fine oh no no that's you Bob worry
about Kelly
what do you think when you look in this
I think it's um delicious it's got an
infection of some kind
I think it's growing internal grapes
that Turtle has a video
I don't worry about as a real sneeze I
think he's just trying to get detention
you got me buddy good Bob because I also
need attention huh
oh my gosh Wade step away from my cabin
I will defend my property this is our
cabin it's not we are a team I will
defend my property I will defend them
can I come in no
hmm oh
how about him
that was very rude you were on my
property
I'm outside
yeah oh my God guys it's cold it shows
you how kind of you make things kind of
not very well but kind of
anyway
back off my property
see that fence line over there hey
Calvin delinea is my property
hey Mark where's the edge of your
property the fence line delineates it oh
the
I your um
is this inside the fence
is over there over there you see over
there
hey Kelvin can you get my friend some
logs and I was doing fine I dropped here
don't worry don't worry kelvin's gonna
help you you helpless idiot I don't need
help because I was already helping my
yeah Calvin come help him Calvin did you
help this man
yeah he's gonna help you I don't need
him you just destroyed the thing that
you said you didn't need help with I
don't it's called the constructive
criticism take it ow I've not
constructed anything so why would I be
taking criticism but my fence line is
delineating how much I need to listen to
you so shut up
your fence line Looks about as awful as
your house you never looked in a mirror
because you apparently don't know what
awful is
so shut up I don't
I only see Glory look look how helpful
Kelvin is Mark
hey wait a minute all right hey hey my
delineation line I um
that's really not what I thought I was
doing I gotta be honest all right all
right look at this the delineation when
you put it in the ground for some reason
I can't pick it back up oh
Mark I've tried to help you delineate
okay this is not helping me to win
that was just temporary storage what am
I doing yeah what are you doing what is
happening
you're just like slowly moving your ax
around staring at it
all right wait you know what guys well I
think what about up here oh oh
you two idiots carry on with that where
did Kelvin go oh he's getting logs for
you you useless piece of [__] look at
him running over here like a champion I
don't see Kelvin oh God Calvin good he's
sleeping like a graceful gazella dope
one of those things
put this here
we're helping I didn't put it there
don't worry Mark we're helping yeah
right
oh oh sorry ow I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm
sorry
I am actually sorry
who put that there I you hit me with an
ax I got scared all right okay we all
are our tempers are flaring
now you can have a thinner walled cabin
oh how would you do that
this doesn't seem to go on here wait I
gotta be honest yeah but it's kind of
cool exploring whoa look at him go oh
Calvin it went right there oh I see what
you're getting at no yeah like what if I
if I just
just yep like that thing that's what I
meant oh ow what you guys okay
I'm like three feet away from me and he
was like yeah
dude the lightning hit right in time
with you going oh yeah
I uh I don't but it's all right man uh
Mark I'm not sure what I'm about to do
but I think I'm about to do something to
your home I don't why would you word it
that way
oh God don't summon the lightning
oh yeah
uh I don't know what the hell we're
doing to the inside of his house what
are you doing to my house you dumb [__]
guys
look I'm trying to I'm trying to help
with your fence delineation Mark and
it's not
I gotta be honest oh hey what's up
Kelvin dude you are such a bro right now
Kelvin oh you are absolutely for some
reason you pick up the [__] oh gee gee
you just dropped stuff if you hit G it
just goes down
oh that's fine good wait oh God no Kevin
Calvin Calvin God damn it Kelvin
wait why are you laughing
what's going on guys
what is what is supposed to be
there's supposed to be a door a window
what is this
what did I ask for help
oh my God oh my God there I I'm not even
looking at it trust anything about it oh
my God you guys just cannot be helped I
think I'll cut some wood because I don't
think I've done much good over there no
no way you've done so Mark I made you a
I made you a new doorway don't worry
about it I didn't have a doorway don't
worry I made you a doorway guys we're
the best of video games can I just say
that where did you wait
there was the doorway was perfectly good
on the other side no no no I fixed it
what do you mean you fixed it I mean I
fixed it what do you mean what do you
mean what do you mean you mean fixed it
what does that mean when I say that I
fixed it did you just throw that at me I
threw it all right whatever I'm making a
firewood pile
so watch your delineations
why is it why is it anything I can throw
logs like their paper dude oh my God
Kelvin
[__] up everything
I'm throwing wood I'm trying to place
firewood oh okay press stack it
perfectly
one
who it disappeared three it's gone there
we go one of them made it it's dark now
don't worry mark
we're almost done with house
I don't think we are we're almost done
with house Mark oops
it's dark
don't worry Calvin oh he's described
freaking come here you come here you you
want to see what this feels like you
want to see how close to death I am you
want to see how close
you wanna see how close you want to see
how close to death I am Barry okay you
missed yeah you missed it's a weird
pissing contest Mark I gotta be honest
I'm so close to death oh man I'm almost
dead
fix them
how'd that feel
yeah what do you think that one yeah
yeah uh-huh
yeah
get shot
who is that where guys guys guys guys
guys guys guys guys guys guys guys guys
guys guys guys guys oh yeah dude
things are getting interesting over here
hello oh oh oh what's happening with the
legs are you seeing the legs it's too
dark I can't see anything wait
it's dark guys guys I let's pitch black
guys fine Mark don't worry about lights
guys why is my lighter purple I don't
like that you have a lighter oh guys she
has yeah no the legs right that's the
thing right no her arms too she has an
extra left over how many how many of her
is there am I why are you so many
bearings I should probably look up what
is wrong with you guys
legs for days oh okay yeah no that's I
can't tell if that's like a bug or like
on purpose you guys are the creepiest
sons of [__] I've ever seen what are
you doing
uh probably not
oh wait I'm gonna I'm gonna Mark come
look at the weight she got up on her
it's literally Pitch Black
oh well get your purple lighter out man
it has a high-pitched sound that hurts
my ears I can't use that
ow why
who did that what are you I don't I
think it was weight I gotta be honest
you're the one working on the house
right now what does that have to do with
anything I guess nothing it's so dark I
can't see anything
that was just actually Kelvin
was that Kelvin yeah he just came over
here and chucked the logs at you I got a
feeling it wasn't though I've been
killed it what the hell I got a feeling
it was weighed I got a feeling oh the
rain stopping are y'all
oh man you guys are the worst you guys
are how do you get out of here you were
I it's not done can you not I'm stuck
and just give me like two seconds hang
on okay okay all right here we
go there hang on
we're getting there hey
ow
there we go
um all right there you go
thank you oh man all right
this is taking some getting used to guys
but we're gonna get through this
together because we are friends honestly
guys we're killing it right is this a
ball
Mark play catch no catch I don't want to
catch oh yeah oh there's a rock
nevermind
looks like a little ball
you know Wade if I didn't know any
better I'd say you're being
intentionally antagonistic
and that's very Unbecoming of you
Fair
doesn't become you at all yeah stop
becoming dude I can't help it sometimes
a pretty lady with an extra arm and
extra leg broke up and I just become
Mark you're coming look what I made for
you my dude what did you make for me my
dude look at what I made for you
uh what did you make for me you have to
get in the hole it's a house what do you
mean what did I it's what what does it
look like what did you make for me my
dude
whoa what the hang on hang on hang on
I'm just I'm putting a door on it
maybe I'm not putting up maybe I just
walled it in oh no there we go hey there
we go
everyone gets the party house baby yeah
[Applause]
oh my God
all right oh window
yo look at the property delineation look
at the delineation look at it God dang
I'm
oh yeah
it's gonna Chuck that out there
stop
he's getting logs and never stopping
stop take a break all right calm down
Calvin down
uh so now that we got it we got a home
all right he's saying it wasn't Kelvin
earlier it was definitely you wait I
know this Mark I'm confused about the
fencing situation yeah what about it I
can't do it I can't seem to do it B for
book
oh of course
B for book Is that real or you lying
it's no he's no 100 I just looked at the
controls to figure it out I don't
believe it I'm a lot more helpful than
you think I don't believe it I don't
believe how how complex can we make
Kelvin be what I did not mean to just
throw a log at you Kelvin I'm deeply
sorry oh he's taking a nap no he's not
he was thinking about it he's bleeding
profusely can we agree just not to use
those lighters well what why does does
it really make a noise yeah it does it's
a high Pizza it's exactly like that
lighter wood in real life it's a high
it's not as loud but it's what happened
I don't hear it at all uh kelvin's
making some kind of shelter I think uh
uh it's a little close to the fire
Kelvin that's fine no it's fine just
don't just don't what am I doing right
now
I do not
Kelvin that's kind of the wrong way
buddy but I appreciate it no no no no no
we're on to it
what's this
that's out of my range of hearing I
cannot hear oh I see what you do whoa I
know right I know right now we can all
sleep under what oh wait wait I assume
it was the floor what do you mean you
thought it was a floor I thought you
were building some elevated platforms
I thought it was like a ham you were
dumb
God dang
you were dumb in that thought not in
general but in that thought okay now
what do you see when you look at this we
don't like the old days here no I'm
sorry you going all day going
observe a little bit of
a of a accusal of misjudgment I didn't
say you were dumb in general I said you
were you were dumb in that moment so
don't twist my words you deserve that
what did you do nothing you'll find out
one day
whatever I'm going to sleep you guys are
we all I'm going to bed I'm going to bed
I'm so hungry I'm so thirsty yeah three
of us apparently Kelvin doesn't count as
people oh
I should do I need to do that yeah get
up but get in the tent oh okay hang on
hang on apparently it's not a hammock no
it's not a hammock hang on guys I'm
building I'm creating I'm creating here
we could see if it was oh okay
what do I need to do sleep it's the
exact same as the four oh wow
oh son oh that's so nice
man we got a little crazy last night I'd
like to start fresh and just say you
guys there's no one I'd rather be
stranded on an island with
if that hit my shelter it would have
been War
it would have been War wait I want you
to know that oh
it's warm it's War what does that mean
it's War it's War now you know Mark I
don't know what happened
look Mark war look Mark War
nope I just threw a rock at your shelter
there we go look Market fixing it I'm
fixing it it's not mine anymore
stay away
Mark I'm fixing it yeah you know you're
like on the GPS right yeah well good
luck finding me
I see her right there I see you yeah
okay
oh yes wow
very good
I
yes yes I found the entertainment bunker
hey Mark I'm on top of you no you're not
what is the was the entertainment bunker
yeah wouldn't you like to know
well you could tell a little holy family
went in Calvin I'm pretty sure I said to
follow me bud
hey I'm hungry and thirsty Mark you got
any food in there yeah there's food in
here oh cool I'm coming
hey can I come
yeah
[Music]
I'm choosing to leave
oh
uh yeah Bob there's some food in there
if you're hungry but not very good why
what is what is what about this is the
entertainment down here it's that whole
ah bats
hey Mark
I don't like it ah
wait what's happening I'm leaving I'm
coming back I'm leaving I'm coming back
Mark I'm very confused
don't worry about it don't worry about
it yeah just um the entertainment bunker
yeah listen uh [__] I think that we are
uh
at War
uscorp outbid Sahara Therapeutics for
remote island
guys you don't think that there's any
kind of like aliens or ghoul monsters on
this island do you
almost definitely not okay cool I found
a lady
what
last night
I don't know I I tried to kill her but
she was unkillable why would you try to
kill her what is wrong with you I don't
know Wade found her I was jealous
[Laughter]
true
you should have seen the first time you
met Molly God that was the most like
succinct example of of humanity wrapped
up in one sentence I've never heard
anything more profound
[Music]
oh